breaking tonight we are getting the
first images of the operation to kill
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi Pentagon officials
just briefing reporters moments ago this
drone footage you're seeing shows
various parts of the raid including the
destruction destruction of the base
after the operation was over and all
actionable intelligence was collected
there six Isis members were told were
killed for women two men
the head of US Central Command says he
expects Isis to try to retaliate for
this mission national security
correspondent Jennifer Griffin is at the
Pentagon with the images and the
briefing good even Jennifer good evening
Brett well we have just received these
first Declassified images from the
Baghdadi compound from the raid just
moments ago the Pentagon released video
showing the moment the compound was
blown up by warplanes using standoff
munitions after the Army special
operators declared jackpot and left the
compound you can see the way it looked
before and you can see the way it looks
the way it looked afterwards so it's
pretty clear that the the success of the
standoff munitions that we employed
ensure that it would not be a shrine or
otherwise memorable in any way it's just
another piece of ground this video shows
the army special operators approaching
the compound on foot from two sides the
11 children inside the compound were
handed over to a trusted source and were
not flown out of Syria Baghdad II
grabbed two not three children when he
hit in the tunnel the US helicopters
were fired at from the ground here you
see the attack helicopters suppress the
gunfire from the air the Singh Kham
commander pushed back on reports the
raid had been moved forward or rushed
due to the president's decision to
withdraw troops
sir you mentioned that you staged from
within Syria was there anything about
the changes on the ground in the last
two to three weeks with the u.s. pulling
back forces with Turkey coming across
that caused you to accelerate this
operation or change the timing of this
operation
Jennifer absolutely not we we chose the
time based on a variety of factors
whether certainty lunar data a variety
of things like that and while it might
have been convenient to use bases there
the United States military has the
capability to go almost anywhere and
support ourselves
general McKenzie revealed for the first
time the US helicopters staged at an
unknown location inside Syria before the
raid something that would have been
infinitely more difficult without any US
forces or partners on the ground
Brett Jennifer Griffin live at the
Pentagon Jennifer thank you